qui sera le candidat des républicains
pour la présidentielle de 2000 22 là
n'était pas la question de ce rendez
vous de la jeunesse l air au port-marly
la rentrée politique du parti organisé
autour des fédérations jeunes ça fait
presque cinq ans que je milite pour le
parti et je n'avais jamais vu autant de
jeunes réunis au même endroit à la fin
de l'été on a pu parler en toute
ouverture de décroissance ou pas de
l'écologie punitive ou alors écologie
plus incitative écologie économie
autorités europe différentes thématiques
d'ateliers organisés autour des élus et
ténors du parti
si l'objectif n'était pas le choix d'un
candidat les discussions se sont
focalisées sur la reconstruction du
parti et d'un programme pour 2022
ce qu'il faut surtout c'est montrer
qu'aujourd'hui on peut travailler
ensemble que de mal gré mal gré les dix
les différences et la richesse
finalement des profils qui existe à
droite ya un socle de valeurs communes
qui est important qui est solide et
c'est sur ça qu'il faut travailler mais
je pense que la préparation de 2022 ce
sera la conséquence de ces travaux je
trouve qu'il ya une convergence en fait
des idées alors il ya des nuances
évidemment ici ou là il ya des gens qui
sont plus préoccupés par l'autorité par
les problèmes de justice de police
d'identité nationale et puis d'autres
plus sur l'économie plus sur
l'intégration pressenti pour être
candidat à la présidentielle françois
baroin annoncera sa décision d'ici à la
fin de l'année les prochaines échéances
électorales pour les républicains seront
les départementales et régionales en
[Applaudissements]